What we're seeing.
What I'm saying at least is that there
should be an evolutionary process to
democracy as there was in Hong Kong and
you mentioned that in the year 2017 Hong
Kong will have universal suffered.
I think that remains very much to be
seen.
I doubt very much whether they will be
genuine and one man,
one vote,
but I would be delighted to be proven
wrong.
Okay.
Can I answer that question?
I think it depends on what you mean by
democracy.
I don't think democracy centers just on
one man,
one vote.
I'm willing to concede that at this
stage,
maybe one man,
one vote is a little too early,
but there are the other aspects of
democracy which I believe to be
important for all nation and for all
human beings and that is human dignity,
some basic rights and freedoms.
The right to participate in the
governance,
to improve the quality of governance,
to have some say in issues that affect
their everyday life,
to have the rule of law,
not the role of men,
not rule by law,
and to have an independent judiciary
that is not subject to the dictates of
the one party system rule.
Now,
I agree with Martin that in the three 30
years since opened our policy that has
been phenomenal economic growth that has
been a degree of personal freedom and
social mobility.
But the sad fact is that in recent years
market economy reforms have stalled and
the government has backtracked on legal
reforms.
All judicial organs in China are now
subject to the dictates of the one party
system rule.
Do we seriously thing that the
population that the 1.3 billion people
in mainland China,
I contend to accept this.
You say that there are mass support for
the one party system role.
Why is it then that we get people in
from mainland coming to Hong Kong to
participate in demonstration,
particularly against the blind dissident
and the young young who was alleged to
have committed suicide
[inaudible].